welcome to popular mattress Liquidators  how can I help you today  I need to buy a new bed okay yeah good  good you came to the right place I'd be  more happy to help with that uh what  size you need a full queen king queen  queen queen oh okay we got a big  selection so you know  it needs to be sturdy all right  okay it's kind of crazy in my room  oh okay I got you brother I got you  well this uh Posturepedic mattress we  got right here that's extremely  comfortable and uh durable  do you mind if I try it no no go ahead  I also mentioned it's a hundred percent  money back guarantee on you yeah yeah  yeah yeah who got that good deed I've  got that good deed yeah yeah  no it's too hard